- Everyone loves you,
you've done so many things,
but, do people, like, out
of all your stuff though,
do people, when you're
in a hardware store,
do they still do--
(Tim and Kelly imitating
dog sounds together)
Do they, yeah, yeah.
- It's, "Grunt for me!"
Y'know, like I'm a little--
one of those little monkeys
that does this, y'know.
- [Kelly] Oh, they ask you?
- But it--
Yeah, they come and--
"Run for me, show the kids,"
or a cop pulls me over,
'cause I have a very high performance car,
and it was making too much
noise, and as soon as the window
goes down he goes-- (imitating dog sound)
(audience laughs)
- [Tim] And I gotta get--
But I'm--
- Hey, if they let you
out of the ticket, I'd--
(imitating dog sound)
- Well, it actually--
- All day long.
- It actually didn't, 'bout
done'em, so I got a double,
but I'm up in--
what is it, Sacramento, and my
wife and I were going through
town and a guy who crossed
the street goes, "Oh, hey!"
Which I like that people
think I have to turn around
when they just yell across the--
"Hey! Hey!"
(audience laughs)
And of course I do, and he goes, "Do you--
(grunting sounds)
"Tool belt!"
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Tool belt, like why?
- Just gets yelled, I go, "What?"
He couldn't quite get the show but it has
something to do with tools and
it was tool belt, and I went,
"Claw hammer!"
- [Kelly] Claw ha-- (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- We went back and forth, I--
I get it--
- Shovel!
- Yeah, shovel.
In this world, it's not like
it was in Home Improvement,
Home Improvement was, I believe
at our top, were 24 million
viewers on a Tuesday night.
- Yeah, but it's true that it
was such a remarkable thing,
that show, I think--
You've done so many amazing
things, but that show was a huge
staple for a lot of people,
that's why they still--
- Well, they did, we did a show--
We got away with stuff, I think, we did--
They did a show on the
Space Shuttle Endeavour
live simulcast on Home
Improvement, we had all the as--
- I missed that one.
- Oh god, it was, 'cause it
looked like it was phony,
and they were floatin' around
in there doing a Tool Time,
on the, it was the mo--
I've got all the stuff at my shop--
- [Kelly] What?
- [Tim] I'm just amazed,
I'm a space freak.
- [Kelly] I'm a space nerd.
- I just love that stuff, and I said,
"What kinda money was this,
who did this," where they're
floatin' around 'cause it was--
the joke was I was doing a
Tool Time and they're all
sleeping 'cause it was so
boring, 'cause they just--
they'd just be floatin' arou--
but they did it live from
the Endeavour Space Shuttle
down to Earth.
- [Kelly] That's so cool!
- Cool is not the word for it.